alright let's talk about golden boy
Trump's son-in-law you disturbing image
by the way of them nice pic Pat and
advisor Jared Kushner who has lost
access to top-secret intelligence I've
reported to you time and again and again
that Jared Kushner has been working with
an interim top-secret security clearance
along with by the way dozens of other
White House staffers I've told you that
Jared Kushner has submitted multiple
incorrect and incomplete disclosure
forms required in the process meant to
get him a security clearance I have been
adamant that Jared Kushner should not
have access to any any top-secret
information nor should he even have a
role in Donald Trump's White House quite
frankly but that's another story and
this is starting to come to a head
because Jared Kushner has now had his
security clearance downgraded as well as
a number of other White House aides who
have been again working with interim top
secret level security clearances but
Jared Kushner is still going to have
access he has not had his clearance
revoked he has had it downgraded from
top secret - secret recall that once
again much of this is self-inflicted
right the reason we even found out that
all of these interim clearances were
being used is that serial accused spouse
abuser Rob Porter had his scandal and we
learned that he had been working for
months after it was made clear that he'd
have trouble getting a security
clearance to put it lightly and then we
learned about the rest of it including
dozens of people as well as Jared
Kushner who were working with these
temporary interim security clearances
now Trump could single-handedly and
unilaterally grant Jared Kushner a
permanent top secret clearance if the
President does it then it will be made
so for for now at least Trump is saying
he's going to leave that up to chief of
staff John Kelly who really has no
credibility any longer because of that
Rob Porter scandal and himself should
resign but no indication at least at
this point that John Kelly is going to
be going bye-bye
so of course since many of
these documents at the secret and top
secret levels are secret we don't
actually know exactly what Kushner will
no longer be able to see but what we do
know because it's been widely reported
is that while Donald Trump is
increasingly not reading the PDB the
presidential daily briefing is sort of
summary of the most relevant and
pressing intelligence from the prior 24
hours Jared Kushner was reading the PDB
and he's no longer going to be able to
Bradley mas who's a lawyer that
specializes in national security law and
clearances of this kind said quote he
cannot see the PDB not a chance
that's interesting now the craziest
thing about all of this is that Jared
Kushner's lawyer seems to be saying you
don't have to worry that Kushner isn't
going to be able to do his job anymore
as advisor because the downgrading of
his top secret security clearance the
secret is not going to impact his
ability to do his job at all does
anybody realize how this is insane if
according to Kushner's own lawyer losing
the top-secret security clearance won't
impact his work at all why did he have a
top secret clearance in the first place
in other words as a basic tenet of
national security and
compartmentalization of information you
don't clear someone especially on an
interim basis higher than is necessary
for them to do their job if we believe
Kushner's lawyer that his job is
completely unaffected by the downgrade
that only raises more questions about
why the kid even was given a top-secret
clearance to begin with do you think
that he'll get that top-secret security
clearance back I suspect that he won't
well and the reason why is because I
think there's a good chance that Jared
Kushner will get indicted by the Muller
I think so too maybe it's not tomorrow
or next week or next month but if you
not only gave him a top secret security
clearance but after taking away give it
back to him I think that's not good for
the Trump well there's you might be
asking me two different questions right
question one is do I think that he would
eventually be granted one through the
normal process the answer is absolutely
not it's abundantly clear after he lied
or conveniently left out dozens and
dozens and dozens of
meetings with foreign people from his
disclosure forms I think there's no
chance that Jared Kushner actually gets
approved for a permanent top secret
security clearance nor should he
the next question is will someone just
say we're gonna give him one anyway
whether it's John Kelly or Donald Trump
I'm also leaning towards no and
certainly if Kushner gets indicted then
absolutely not and I'm guessing that if
that were the case he would step back
from his role in the administration
which I think he might be going in the
direction of anyway it's the dumb sort
of leading and representing the dumb
here and I was reading online comments
about this and to many people it almost
seems and I'm talking about people on
the left here they seem to be sort of
relishing in how things are going poorly
for Jared Kushner like their their
cheerleading that his security clearance
has been downgraded because they feel
it's a sort of insult to cook to Jared
Kushner I think that's the wrong
approach right this was a national
security risk this was sloppy handling
of top secret information we should be
concerned about this as a national
security issue rather than feeling like
we won because something was taken away
from Jared Kushner listen I understand
the pleasure that people might
experience at reading these headlines
but this is fundamentally a national
security thing and in the end more than
likely Kellie I believe is not going to
give Kushner the clearance because Kelly
doesn't want to be further wrapped up in
this type of nonsense with Trump and I
think from what we're reading that the
Kelly Trump sort of a confrontation may
well come to a head we're reading that
the Trump family is increasingly very
much at odds with John Kelly I think
it's more likely that Kelly leaves then
that he gives Jared Kushner whose
clearance
I think so too especially because Kelly
runs a very tight ship and it seems
yellow Jared and Ivanka have been able
to circumvent the normal ranks of the
White House and can obviously speak
directly to the president whereas other
officials can't I don't disagree with
you that in some general sense Kelley
does run a tighter ship at least than
was previously run by Reince Priebus
although the fact that Kelly knew Porter
had multiple wife-beating ionisation
against him and allowed him to continue
working for months and months on these
interim clearances
that really soured my perception of
Kelly as the supposedly elegant guy that
Donald Trump liked like to refer to him
as so anyway not good news for Jared
Kushner today's program is brought to
you in part by Blink Asst so you read
books I read books and if you're at all
like me you probably don't have time in
your schedule to read all the books that
you want to read there is an entire
world of nonfiction books out there that
could really feed your knowledge and
infla intellect but the sad truth is
that you're only able to read or tiny
fraction of those books but what you
could still do is absorb the most
essential knowledge from the books that
you don't have time to read and that's
exactly where blinka comes in it's an
app that takes nonfiction books pulls
out the most important points and
insights from the books and it puts them
in a condensed sort of packaged form
which you can either read or listen to
in about 15 minutes on your mobile
device or tablet and over four million
people are already using blink as' made
the iTunes best apps of 2017 list and
you can choose from a selection that is
huge thousands of books all of which
you'll have access to as a blinka
subscriber and you can switch between
text and audio both online and offline
get personalized recommendations based
on the books you've already chosen blink
astiz free to try and membership after
that is only a few bucks a month but you
can get a 20% discount if you go to
blink accom slash Pakman and if you're
watching on youtube we are linking a
tube Linkous and our link in the video
description one more time that is blink
is comm /p a que ma n